about to step backwards it's gonna
happen actually within three moves
um okay let's just while magnus thinks
just very briefly let's bring up the
board because there's one killer idea in
the position he plays it he drops his
queen back
this queen is simply going to take this
pawn and bring herself to the bottom of
the board
and the white king is stuck the white
king has no escape squares that
it's trapped by the two black knights
this is gonna happen rook takes born
queen takes checkmate is coming um okay
the players are playing so fast um we
did see a
bishop capture of the knight a check
once king had to move another check the
king had to run
another check the king has continuing
its journey
this king now is caught in the middle i
think all black needs to do
well every move is winning here but all
black needs to do is to maybe even push
this pawn forward and
this checkmate is coming soon just cover
this square
wow knuckle does he just resigns he
doesn't even wait to see magnus's move
it's over wow the drama
magnus carlsen winning game three he's
trying
the second match and that means